hey guys it's justine and today's video
is going to be a little bit different i
actually
left the house and i had the best time
ever so as you know
our lives do revolve a lot around our
phones so with the mainstream adoption
of 5g
we are quickly entering into an entirely
new era of speed and connectivity i
partnered with t-mobile to do a road
trip from here
los angeles all the way to phoenix to
test out their 5g network they have
america's largest 5g network and they
even have coverage in all 50 states with
their extended range 5g we'll be able to
average
two times faster speeds than on a
t-mobile 4g lte network now i use the
samsung galaxy s 21 plus 5g
as my main device for everything
navigation
music streaming places to stop content
creation and even used it to tether to
my computer
and the speeds that i was getting on
this thing it just blew my mind so i
thought it'd be really fun to add
another element into this 5g
test so i asked you guys for some
suggestions of some random things to
take photos or videos of
so you'll be seeing that throughout the
trip i think though what
really impressed me the most is how much
coverage t-mobile had during the entire
drive from la to arizona
i have done this drive so many times and
i was pleasantly surprised with almost
always being connected even in the
middle of the desert and now my friends
let's officially start this vlog off
with me being about
five hours late to pick up my sister
jenna and our dog maddie would you be
surprised if i said
i was late and we were supposed to leave
three hours ago
i had to finish packing oh
how much gear are you gonna need for one
simple little road trip
it's so heavy the answer would be this
much
and i should be just enough room for all
the jenna's things after i kind of fit
in all the last minute accessories
gotta pack the essentials
it has started raining i've hit the curb
i'm pathetic
i think we pack way too much stuff yeah
there's a lot we might need it
we might sounds like we did we might so
we're in the car i'm four hours late
five hours i think at this point yeah
you wanted to leave at seven i'm like oh
i'm not ready so
like realistically nine will work for me
i woke up before you know what's great i
was gonna ask you what the address was
of where we're going and it just popped
up
in my notifications also i need to put
some tape over the logo of my car
you know why jenna it's a sponsored
video
not sponsored by my car you can't even
[Music]
tell
seven minutes left we've had a lot of
different weather over the course of an
hour and
we're uh we got 5g
making our first stop 4 hours 45 minutes
ago
[Music]
okay what do you want i don't know
i need to get a case for this
yeah it's not working out so well is it
going so well
no well buddy sorry
okay but look at that muffin in there it
is shining it's shimmering
it is absolutely splendid well we've got
5g
and we also have four hours 47 minutes
well let me know what you want me to
drive
okay i'm just gonna be over here
did you see that yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
i do have to make a second potty break
so i think we're gonna
exit here see that see that did you see
that
you see that
[Music]
finishing up the road trip there it is
5g
[Music]
one hour 22 minutes we still have 5g
this is crazy because a lot of these
places that we've been driving through
normally i hardly even have reception at
all we're thinking about dinner we're
gonna order dinner
so that it'll arrive basically like
five minutes after we get there i should
probably start searching now
i booked this place last night like we
had no idea where were we gonna stay i
was like we gotta find somewhere and of
course
pets welcome food is here it has arrived
they gave us silverware for like eight
people
i got this healthy salad but then i also
got cauliflower buffalo
wings and a meatball that's wrapped in
like a
noodle
you see bubble that's all over my speed
test thing so tyler
edited our podcast and now i need to
download it and i'm so shocked because
the tethering speed of my t-mobile
5g phone almost double the wi-fi of this
house which is kind of shocking
7 8 upload
[Music]
go to arizona do a scavenger hunt hunt
for 5g
and you think the weather's going to be
nice guess what it is torrential
downpours
we don't have any supplies like we don't
have an umbrella we don't janna doesn't
have boom
socks so we're gonna go to the mall and
test out the 5g in the parking lot and
get jenna some boots
i've been pretty impressed with my speed
so far it's honestly
faster than my internet at home does
that thing have a compass
it's telling you where to go west i need
like
right left almost all of these stores
have huge signs out front that say store
closing here we are everyone
reporting to you not live at the mall we
are going to do a 5g test right here
at the mall so here's our t-mobile check
we have 37.4 download 41.3
upload that's wild then here on verizon
we have 15.2 download
and 13 megs up so the thing is like
there's gonna be different speeds pretty
much everywhere you go
but the best part about having the
t-mobile network is how broad it is
that you'll have more expansive 5g yes
some places will be faster than others
but here at the mall t-mobile reigns
king
or queen there's snow on that person's
car no it has snowed in arizona
we were inside the mall we missed
everything this
this is snow freaking snow
in arizona i've been having so much fun
just going around and doing random speed
tests
picture of you going down a slide bonus
points if it's a water slide and guess
what
it's been raining so technically i think
i get bonus points
look at this there's water that's water
i gotta take a picture
i can't fit through here okay
all right gotta get this picture oh
oh that was fun
[Music]
there's a lot of gulping
i'm so glad that one of our scavenger
hunt items was to go golfing thanks
jenna evac
[Music]
scavenger hunt continues it has been
raining pretty much non-stop which makes
it ideal for a rainbow
there it is oh my goodness
got the rainbow scavenger hunt's going
well
we've also got we've also got 5g
jen look at this 283 download 52
upload this is fun it's like
a 5g scavenger hunt
so in this location we currently have 99
down and 57
up still faster than my home upload
yeah maybe take a seat lady let's take a
look up there
oh boy
[Music]
we hit the top and jenna has verizon
i have att on my phone and on my s21
plus that i'm filming on right now has
the t-mobile
and we just did a speed test oh my
goodness i have 5g on top of the mod
now on t-mobile i have 28 down 18 up and
on 18t
i have 8 down and 2.3 up what did you
have on yours jenna
i think i had 11 down and 11 up and
that's on verizon
so our dog maddie has a best friend
named yossi and yossi used to live in
california and then yossi moved to
arizona so while we're here
we're doing a meet-up of the previous
best friends
okay this is what you get for being a
good boy
maddie you've met your friend and guess
what else
we've got fast 5g so we've got 103
download
12 upload get a statement put a
statement that's a microphone
speak into it
[Music]
all right friends what do we see here do
we see
something maybe some 5g
perhaps i
found it okay everybody's inside is
looking at me i have to go away now
i've got to go away
[Laughter]
[Music]
so the place that we're staying has a
batting cage and this is basically the
reason
that we decided to stay here i haven't
played any sort of baseball softball in
like a very very very long time so see
what happens
[Music]
oh lord he's coming at me
yeah keep your eye on the ball okay
we'll watch
that one so i don't think i'm gonna be
getting drafted by any professional
baseball or softball leagues anytime
soon
anyway we're gonna go for a hike it's
our last evening here
so we're gonna enjoy the rest of the day
i'm searching for a hike that we can do
this 5g is great because it's so much
faster than our wi-fi i'm even watching
my own youtube videos
did you see the new set that we've been
working on yeah it looks good
i'm so excited
i think we go this way and then we come
back here we come here but we don't it's
a loop we come back here
we start here we end here
it's actually probably gonna get dark
very soon so
we need to walk quick like i'm zooming
into the moon i'm kind of freaking out a
little bit because i looked down and i
saw my shadow and it's not from the sun
my friends it is from the moon i am
seeing
my moon shadow right now i saw mine too
so it's real
thank you guys so much for watching this
video i honestly had so much fun doing
it and i feel
so inspired and kind of just
reinvigorated to make content being able
to kind of get out and safely
explore was something that i desperately
needed so a huge thank you to t-mobile
for making that possible and really
fueling that entire trip i was so
surprised with the consistency of the
speeds that i was getting in
various places from not only from los
angeles but all the way
up to arizona so i had so much fun on
that trip and
i hope that you guys enjoyed the vlog if
there's anything else you would like to
see me make in the future for another
fun video
feel free to leave it in the comments
below and i will see you guys in the
next one
bye
[Music]